I'm Laura Ingram this is Andrew mangle
from Washington tonight to Joe or not to
Joe that's the focus of tonight's angle
now Johnny Carson he knew when to retire
he did it when he was on top
I'm one of the lucky people in the world
I found something I always wanted to do
and I have enjoyed every single minute
of it can only tell you that it has been
an honor
and a privilege to come into your homes
all these years and entertain you
got on another season or two but he knew
better
he said I realized I could go off the
air right now and the show could be a
legend or I could make some more money
smart
then there are those who just can't let
go
share kicked off her wildly successful
living proof farewell tour which began
in 2002 and gross 250 million dollars
worldwide
only it wasn't a farewell at all in 2014
she hit 49 cities in her Dressed To Kill
Tour
[Music]
yeah
okay two two farewell tours totally fine
maybe
but there was a third farewell tour
shares Here We Go Again Tour kicked off
in 2018 and that ended a few years later
in 2020. but at least with Cher's long
goodbye there are a lot of great costume
changes and music Nostalgia but if Biden
sticks around all America will get is an
economy and Decline and a first lady in
denial
he's not done
he's not finished what he started look
at all that Joe has
has done has accomplished I mean he
brought us
out of the chaos is all that's left at
this point is just to figure out a time
and place for the announcement
pretty much
pretty much that tells us who's in
charge
apparently someone interviewed my wife
today I heard I heard that too just
before I came in I got a call and find
out now all can you decide my intention
is from it hasn't been done from
beginning to run but there's too many
other things I have to finish in the
near term before I started campaign but
voters see that he's already finished
doing quite a bit Biden's policies
killed our energy Independence stoked
inflation blew trillions on idiotic
coveted payments drove up food and gas
prices
and none of this is going to age well
and speaking of age
is your age part of your own calculation
into whether to run again no uh but it's
legitimate for people to raise issues
about my age it's totally legitimate to
do that and the only thing I can say is
watch me
oh we're watching all right
I did a whole video I mean
what the hell
on
Doom zoom zoom I like it every time I
think of Zoom that song of my generator
who's zooming who
wait wait let me answer the question
that's not your Generation by the way
nice try though the fact is the Democrat
establishment sees what we see and they
know what we know Biden is fading he's
unsteady and he's faltering before our
eyes
no serious person believes that he's
capable of making his own decisions
about complex questions at foreign or
domestic policy do you have any plan to
travel to Ohio and have you talked with
the mayor yet I I can't recall that I
don't think I've talked to the mayor I
talked to everyone else there and I'm
multiple times talked to both the
Senators both like both Governors I've
talked to everyone there is to talk to
both Governors what
and now journalists with top Democrat
Party sources they're reporting about
the worry within the party that's
building
a few weeks ago it was Jonathan Martin
noting that senior Democrats worry Biden
is too old for a second term
and today it was Mark leibovich in the
Atlantic also noting the worry the
Democrats have in private about Biden's
age and wishing he'd step aside
the public silence around the
president's predicament has become
tiresome and potentially catastrophic
for the Democratic party somebody should
make a refreshing nuisance of themselves
and involve the voters in this decision
now one of the few elected Democrats
discouraging a second Biden run is
Minnesota's Congressman Dean Phillips
who says that the president's approval
rating has many Democrats freaking out
believe me there are literally hundreds
in Congress he said who would say the
same thing
but they simply won't blank say a word
there's also the very real concern about
Kamala Harris
since it's possible of course that Biden
wouldn't be able to finish a second term
former Clinton lawyer Greg Craig writes
Biden should tell his party that he'll
not dictate who will be his running mate
but instead leave it up to the delegates
to pick the person who is best equipped
to take on that task
now wait a sec wait a second are they
implying that should it be necessary
understudy Kamala Harris isn't prepared
for the leading role I just love the
idea of exploring the unknown
I love electric school buses
I just love them for so many reasons
maybe because I went to school on a
school bus I really loved Venn diagrams
you know the circles right three usually
to check if you qualify
go to get internet.gov
to check if you qualify go to
internet.gov
[Music]
this is a an absolute nightmare for the
Democrats plus everyone knows that
there's a huge appetite for someone OTB
other than Biden in 2024 58 percent of
Democrats and Democratic leaning
Independents support the idea of
nominating someone else
and let's not forget Biden's implicit
2020 promise that he'd be a one-termer I
view myself as a bridge not as anything
else there's an entire generation of
leaders you saw stand behind me they are
the future of this country
uh he was a bridge all right a bridge to
nowhere or maybe a bridge to the first
doctor
is there any chance at this point that
he's not going to run
uh
not in my book
you're all for it I'm all for it of
course
how imperious
it's all about them
what the country desperately wants and
needs just doesn't matter
so I was nervous as some Republicans are
about a politically damaging blood feud
between Trump and DeSantis
the Democrats have reason to be far more
nervous
they have an incumbent with a bad record
and a bad memory
of course publicly liberals try to
really try hard to appear calm
you don't need to be nervous I mean we
gotta feel people should just jump in
let's jump in let people jump in you got
Marion Williamson out there saying she
may run so he should be challenged
president absolutely he should be
challenged this is democracy this is not
a dictatorship voters deserve to have
Choice period
yes they do deserve a choice and
Republicans will have lots of options
but that's wishful thinking for the
Democrats
so I have to say sorry Gavin sorry JB
sorry gretchman Gretchen you're gonna
have to wait your turn
and in 2024 the voters who've gotten
shafted these past few years they'll
finally have their turn
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else